gare de Montini samedi dernier le soleil
était au rendez-vous et ses militants
antinucléaire aussi en tout une
vingtaine de personnes direction Paris
pour grossir l'une des chaînes humaines
qui encerclit les lieux de décision sur
le nucléaire pour ces ivelinois le Sénat
un événement national organisé par le
collectif sortir du nucléaire 2 ans
après la catastrophe de Fukushima Esther
a connu près de chez elle un accident
sur une centrale et est convaincu de la
nécessité une transition énergétique je
trouve ça une technologie très très
dangereuse je viens de de la Hongrie où
j'ai vécu le le catastrophe de
tchernoby j'ai peur
pour pour nos enfants et je trouve que
une négligence humaine est toujours
possible collectif et partis politiqu
présents rejoignaient ses propos parmi
eux Europe écologil les vert pour qui la
présence du parti au gouvernement
n'empêche pas des prises de contre le
pouvoir en place ce sujet du nucléaire
il faut qu'on continue nous dans la rue
à faire pression et le fait qu'il y ait
des ministres au gouvernement ne nous
empêche pas d'avoir une opinion qui est
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus volontariste
que ce que le Parti socialiste met en
œuvre aujourd'hui le train arrive il est
temps d'y aller pour ces militants
d'après les organisateurs ils étaient
20000 dans la capitale 4000 selon la
police selon un sondage hiop pour West
France 42 % des Français se disent
inquiets à propos des centrales
nucléaires